Speaker 1: All right.
We've got to get to something really, really
important.
This needs to be I am going to show you a
video that justifies launching a new investigation
into Republican Congressman Jim Jordan and
whether he was an accomplice in a greater
way than we already knew to the January 6th
riots.
Think back a week to when Nancy Pelosi said
Jim Jordan and Jim Banks can't be on this
committee investigating the January 6th riots.
And at the time, I said Jim Jordan is more
likely a witness or a coconspirator than he
can really in any realistic way be an investigator
of what took place on January 6th.
He appeared yesterday on Fox News with Bret
Bair and Bret Baier asked him, did you speak
to Trump on January 6th?
And Jim Jordan is caught obviously trying
to obfuscate.
You've got to see this.
Let's listen to it line by line.
OK, here we go.
Speaker 2: I mean, he's obviously going to
go down a number of different roads about
who knew what when, who was talking to coordinators
of the protests, did you talk to the former
president that day?
I've talked to the former president umpteen
times.
Thousands.
I mean, I may not.
Speaker 1: OK, did you talk to the president
on January 6th?
And Jordan says, I've talked to the president
umpteen times.
And Brett Bair tries to clarify exactly the
date on which he's referring to the former
Speaker 2: president umpteen times thousands.
I mean, I may not that I mean, on January,
countless, countless times I talked to the
president.
I never talk about what we talk about.
Speaker 1: OK, so he still now he says, I
talked to the president.
He's still not saying on that day, but it
seems to be what he's conceding here.
Speaker 2: That's appropriate because I can
only talk about what happens in Republican
conferences, talk to the president numerous
times.
I continue to talk to the president on January
six.
Congressman.
Yes.
I mean, I talk to the president.
I've talked to the president, so I can't remember.
Speaker 1: So he seems to be realizing he
can't just lie and say no.
And he seems to be realizing I is going to
keep asking the question.
So he tries to slide it in and says yes, meaning
yes.
I did speak to Trump on January six, but I've
talked to him so many times, I can't even
remember all the times I've talked to him
Speaker 2: for all the days I've talked to
him, but I've certainly talked to the president.
Yeah.
And on that day was can you share any of the
inside of what he was thinking about that
day?
Speaker 1: Very clear question.
What's the relevance?
The relevance is I alone can fix it.
The book from Carol Lenegan Philip Rucker
says it has multiple sources who say Trump
was basically giddy on January 6th.
The reason Trump didn't send in the National
Guard is he loved what was going on.
He was giddy.
He was absolutely loving it.
And my guess is that when Jim Jordan spoke
to Trump, Trump expressed being thrilled about
what was going on.
Now, what Jim Jordan said, we don't know.
But it's obvious why Jim Jordan doesn't want
to talk about what that conversation was like,
a
Speaker 2: breath of people.
We need to come testify.
Are the people who can testify to the fundamental
questions?
Speaker 1: Well, one of those people might
be Jim Jordan.
What exactly was Trump's mental state when
you spoke to him?
Was he giddy about the riots?
Speaker 2: Why didn't the United States Capitol,
the People's House, have an appropriate security
posture on that day?
And what have we done?
Those are the people we need to hear from
those that's information and testimony we
need to get.
That's what we should focus on.
But I don't think that Bennie Thompson, the
chairman of this committee, said
Speaker 1: the question wasn't about Bennie
Thompson.
You know, the question was about your conversation
with Trump.
Speaker 2: Things on the table until we raised
this issue about the speaker's office is the
one who knows what the security posture and
why it was the way it was once we raised that
question, said, well, everything's on the
table.
Speaker 1: OK, so he clearly doesn't want
to talk about what he said to Donald Trump.
Now, what do we know about Jim Jordan?
Well, we know that Jim Jordan was part of
a meeting of House Republicans that took place
in advance of January 6th about how to overturn
the election.
We know Jim Jordan was there.
It's been widely reported.
We are aware that on December 21st of twenty
twenty, Marjorie Taylor Green, Matt Gaits,
Jim Jordan, Mo Brooks and Louie Gohmert, really
a cast of characters were spotted at the White
House.
And the reports are that they met with Donald
Trump.
So we know Jim Jordan met with Trump about
how to overturn the results in advance of
January six.
We know that Jim Jordan voted against certifying
the results and we now know that Jim Jordan,
through his obfuscation and his distraction,
we know that Jim Jordan also spoke to Donald
Trump on January six.
We also know that Trump was reportedly giddy
on January 6th about the riots.
We also know that Donald Trump was responsible
for the military not getting to the capital
as quickly as they could have on January 6th.
And here is the slow drip about the truth
of Jordan's potential role on January 6th.
My guess is that Jordan's fingerprints are
all over the January 6th riots.
I'm sure there was lots of locker room talk
about it.
And the idea I mean, imagine Jim Jordan tried
to argue his way into being an investigator
of the January 6th riots.
Good for Nancy Pelosi for saying you can't
be on the panel, Jim.
And the reality is we now know it is that
this guy is almost certainly a witness to
the inciting of that in his conversation with
Donald Trump.
And he may even be an accomplice in what took
place on January 6th.
Unbelievable.
Truly unbelievable